okay well let's bring you some breaking
news here now these are pictures of
old trafford where fans have now spilled
out onto the pitch
that's what you're seeing there on your
screens um manchester united fans
angered by the european super league
plans
calling for the glazer family uh to
be removed as owners calling for them to
go momentum building up against them
that's what you're seeing there
manchester united fans are now
on the pitch at old trafford they were
protesting earlier
outside the team's hotel which is also
highly unusual uh protesting outside
lowry now they have
stepped out onto the pitch you can see
the
colored flares there as well uh chanting
and clapping they're calling for the
glazer family to go
that's because of the increased anger
after the european super league
short-lived of course just over around
50 hours or 56 hours it lasted but
nevertheless that anger did spill out we
did see fans protesting then enough
protest then for the european super
league to be scrapped
now that protest has spilled out onto
the pitch at
old trafford ahead of a big match there
um
at 4 30 the kickoff between man united
and liverpool an important premier
league
match of course notably for manchester
city who are hoping to win the premier
league
if manchester united lose but looks like
there is
a lot to be done before that match can
take place as
uh look you can see younger people older
fans
everyone who's been angered by that move
by
amongst others of course manchester
united and the glazer family
and the top six teams from the premier
league of course planning
to go into the european super league
gonna switch up the pitchers now to
outside old trafford as you can see
there
uh hundreds more soon probably
thousands as fans have been invited of
course back into stadiums but
of course it seems that fans are just
gathering
maybe they don't have tickets to get in
but they are angry of course about
the european super league let's just
take a listen to what's happening
so you can hear there are groups of fans
just a little
a few seconds ago while i was speaking
we did hear fireworks going off crackers
going off
we've seen colored flares as well of
course so
it seems that that protest is building
up outside
and inside old trafford
fans they're on the pitch it doesn't
seem to be
many stewards around trying to stop them
usually of course there are stewards
lining up
between the seats and the pitch
this is the very latest pictures coming
into us at sky news center and we're
about to take you live
now to what's happening right now it
seems to have cleared up a little bit
that's inside
old trafford on the pitch still some
litter of course strewn across
um just about two hours to go before
kickoff at old trafford four manchester
united and
liverpool for that big premier league
match tonight but um
fans have been protesting earlier
outside the team hotel the lowry hotel
in manchester
and then a few moments ago as you saw on
those pictures fans strewn out
across the pitch outside the stadium as
well
at old trafford so just to update you if
you're just tuning in
we are bringing you pictures from old
trafford where
manchester united fans protesting
against
the european super league and calling
for the glazer family the owners
to go took their protest out onto the
pitch
at manhu those are pictures obviously
outside as well
as people gathered outside
and just about two hours to go and
as i was saying for that kickoff for
this afternoon's
match between manchester united and
liverpool it'll be interesting to see
what they decide about whether they can
stick to
that kickoff time in fact 4 30. it did
look like
um the pitch might have been cleared but
there's still litter there's still of
course protests going on
outside and many of these fans
presumably
have tickets so will they still be
allowed in to watch the match as it goes
on of course fans have only recently
been allowed
back into stadiums uh to watch the
premier league after
corona virus didn't look like there were
many stewards or police on hand to clear
but that does seem to be happening now
um right you can see there we go
pictures coming into us right now of
a mixture of stewards and
fans running around across the pitch
people trying to take control
of the situation there so a very quick
update for you again
manchester united due to play liverpool
at 4
30 kickoff this afternoon important
premier league match
as the season comes to an end fans
protesting
against the glazer family and the
european super league
which was had to be scrapped because of
previous protests
now calling for the glazer family to go
they have taken their protest onto the
pitch
at manchester united at old trafford for
their home ahead of their home match
outside the team hotel at the lowry and
outside
the stadium you can see there's a bit of
chaos there as people struggled
to take control of the situation